recycling at Sky central just as these
bottles begin their journey to be
reprocessed I'm on the road to make a
point about so many others the ones
littered on the ground that's more than
700,000 everyday in the UK according to
new research so many that if he were to
lay them out end-to-end that stretched
90 miles from West London to Bristol
where the study was carried out Keep
Britain Tidy says recycling at home is
easy the problem is food and drink
bought on the go it is a national
problem and what you're seeing is 10% of
people dropping dropping dropping
whatever it is that they feel that they
no longer need and not thinking about
the rest of us and we've really got to
address that behavior because it you
know we spend about a billion pounds a
year picking up this and that is money
that could be better spent on all sorts
of other things the Highways Agency is
responsible for litter picking on
England's motorways collecting seven and
a half thousand tonnes a year a service
station on route plenty of bins here but
still bottles are strewn along the slip
road appalling when you compare as well
and say the likes of France so it's a
different France moving back to France
in fact totally different where I used
to live down in the Alps you wouldn't
see it at all how do you change other's
mentality it's difficult education is a
start but it's not everything is it it's
difficult people have got to work
alongside the road and click roads now
putting their lives in danger and stuff
back on the road measuring out that line
of littered bottles barely half of all
those we buy are recycled some of the
rest are blown or washed out to sea
breaking down to become toxic fish food
there is another way if we paid a
deposit of say 10 15 P on every bottle
that we bought but then got the cash
back when we returned the empty
recycling rates are likely to double
that's the scheme they have in Norway
and they're 96% of bottles go back into
the
almost in Bristol home to the
environmental consulting group eunomia
which has been looking at the litter
problem they calculate deposits would
reduce the number of bottles dropped on
the ground by at least 85% that's
600,000 everyday people want to get
their money back it's not just a reward
scheme not just being rewarded for
taking it back
the deposit is paid upfront people get
their money back so I think that
incentive just a small incentive it's
been shown to work elsewhere there's no
reason why I can't work here Scotland is
already drawing up plans for bottle
deposits in England MPs are looking at
the evidence pressure is growing on the
UK government to act and use financial
incentives to stop so many bottles
ending up on our roadsides Thomas More
Sky News